the minimalists are once again going on
tour this is our tenth tour in ten years
it is called the les Coast tour will be
hitting eight cities across the west
coast of the United States and Canada
for more details head on over to the
minimalists comm slash tour we'll see
you soon
and minimalists hello everybody welcome
to the minimalist podcast where we
discuss what it means to live a
meaningful life with less my name is
Joshua Fields Milburn and I'm Ryan
Nicodemus and together we are the
minimalist today we're gonna talk about
student debt we're gonna talk about
graduating from a university without any
debt at all and we're gonna talk about
tips for avoiding college debt
altogether with today's guests Anthony
O'Neill is back Anthony is the author of
debt-free degree it's a new book I'll
hold it up if you're watching on YouTube
here Anthony thank you for joining us
yeah thanks man here my brothers man
it's good to see you man Wow yeah last
time we saw you was when we were in
Nashville right Nashville then I did
jaws podcast I'm at a theater I can't
permanent so we've been together a lot
man last time we seen each other
I had to beat y'all in TopGolf but other
than oh my god I'm so awful ago I feel
bad when people ask me to play any type
of golf because they expect like maybe
some type of you know competitive level
and I just got I got nothing you know
I'm excited for this episode because we
get so many questions about about debt
with respect to going to college and so
many people they just assume they have
to take on five or even six figures
worth of debt well it feels like one of
those good excuses right like oh it's
okay to go into debt because I'm I'm
working towards a degree and that degree
will help me graduate and then I can
start to pay off the debt that I've
accumulated to get the degree and so
many people are doing it Anthony I think
because so many other people are doing
it it is normal I mean you know we see
it right now one point six trillion
dollars in student loan debt you know so
it's normal but when we really step back
and look at it normal is not setting up
our young people to succeed and win not
just young people just people in general
who take out student loans and them and
something you say Ryan was that you know
a lot of people think they'll get the
money and they'll get a job and pay back
their student loans but studies is also
showing man that nearly 20 years after
they graduate college they still owe 50%
of the original student loan so it's
like they're not getting the jobs
they're not getting the ink
paid off let's hop into some of these
questions here we have a bunch of
questions from our audience the first
one is from Gwyn in well a college town
Athens Ohio hi Josh my name is Gwen and
I'm from Athens Ohio
let me think about education so again
I'm here doing my bachelor's in music
and I'm striving for PhD but I know I'm
gonna go into debt I know it's going to
cost stress and I'm not sure if it's
going to add value to my life or my life
work from just repot Thanks
alright Anthony so I think she's right
about one thing if she goes into debt it
is gonna call stress but she said I know
I'm going to go into debt and that's the
regular attitude and in your book
debt-free degree you I mean I mean it
says it all on the title but in the book
itself and we're gonna dive in a little
bit more into the book here in a bit but
you outline a plan that hey you can get
a degree without going into debt yeah
you know when I listen to go in the very
first thing she says is I know I'm going
to get into debt she says I know is
going to call stress but then listen to
the third part she said right there I do
not know if it's going to add value and
so my very first thing is before I even
go into college you guys I'm taking debt
off of the table I'm taking student
loans off of the table now I'm not
against continuing education if you want
to get your masters your PhD that's
great I mean but let's step back and
let's do a vision as have a plan and see
and assess is me going with me going
back to school will this add value to me
where they bring in more income I'm or
is it am I just doing it just because
you know cuz if you go get a master's
degree you may come out make an extra
ten thousand twenty thousand dollars a
year but it's gonna cost you another
hundred thousand so is that a good ROI
no it's not so for her for Glenn it to
everyone else listening I would say
let's step back one take debt off at a
table come up with the plan and let's do
the research and make sure that if we
continue the education is it bringing
value no stress and more income yeah the
worst reason she could go to college is
just because I know a lot of people who
will stay in continuing education just
to avoid paying back
loans which is which is even a worse
plan because it's like oh I'm gonna stay
in a school accumulate more debt so I
can avoid paying this debt that I've
already incurred
so when yeah I mean my advice is like
you got to get behind the why like why
do you want that PhD if it's just
because you've got a you know you talked
about the warning signs you talked about
imagine you're so I did too when I was
reading that with you in an orange vest
is a clear warning sign like yeah Gwen
you've got to rethink about what you're
going to do with this with this decision
now there may be a really good reason
but you gotta figure out what that
reason is it isn't just because and
certainly isn't to avoid student debt
that you've already incurred and if the
reason is so you can have three
additional letters behind your name or
you can call yourself doctor that's
that's not a very good reason but you
dr. Milburn all the time you know the
PhD thanks dr. nicodemus alright so I
think when we're talking to win and he's
absolutely right there are three
components here is this going to stress
me out if so how do I eliminate the
stress well it's that first component of
if I can go without without debt now I
often have people tell me
Anthony they'll say well I know I'm
gonna have to accumulate debt to become
a nurse and it's like well let me ask
you this has there ever been anyone in
the history of Nursing who has gone to
college gotten their degree without any
debt and they'll say well yeah I'm sure
there's plenty of people done oh well
then you have plenty of recipes right
there right plenty of a minute just just
last week Dave and I were talking about
this Dave Ramsey he's talking about well
you're my mentor Dave Ramsey and we was
interviewing six students and one of
them went to school and got her nursing
degree 100% debt free and it's so funny
when I hear people like that say I have
to go into debt I met a young lady who
got her PhD 100% debt free here's the
thing people just do not want to work
they don't want to put the hard work and
be patient behind it they want the quick
fix microwave process to get in there
degree well you know it's interesting to
is like people want the quick fix and
they tell themselves I'll work harder
later yeah so I'm gonna I'm gonna go and
do the easy thing now but then when I
get that too
work really really hard and half that
fast it's like work hard now like that
if you're not willing to work hard now
you're probably not willing to work hard
later that is making your future self
suffer for your current indiscretions
you could tweet that pocket a shot yes
and so the last thing I want to talk to
Gwen about our value she said I don't
know if this is gonna add value to
anyone's life that is because you may
not be clear on what your values are
right now and how you can best
contribute to the world around you maybe
that is by obtaining your PhD and that's
going to be a way for you to contribute
if so great there is going to be a
debt-free way for you to do that
but let's say you do get through college
and you get your PhD and you're
debt-free but then you still don't use
it well then you've kind of wasted your
time right and it's okay to realize I've
wasted some time up until now those are
sunk costs you can always pivot away so
you don't have to continue wasting your
time going forward Gwen I want to send
you a copy of debt-free degree I think
you're really going to enjoy I think
you'll get a lot of value from that
it'll help you make some decisions also
if you check out our values podcast
episode number 69 you'll you'll find
some value in that because we go into
getting really clear on what your values
are oh and uh next question is from
Maura
in Australia hi I'm Josh and Ryan my
name is Maura I'm 19 years old and I'm
from Bombay Australia through out your
financial podcast and whenever anyone
asks you about college debt you often
tell them to find people who have
completed the degree that they want to
do and to try and get advice off them or
follow their recipe
but where can I find someone that's done
integrate that I want to do is there a
platform Maura the good news is is you
don't have to find someone who has done
your degree exactly I mean yes Josh and
I we have in the past recommended you
know I remember one specific event
someone was talking about being a lawyer
and they were like oh man I really want
to be a lawyer I got to go to college
for that I got to go into debt and we
were like no like you don't you could
probably find a lawyer who has gone
through it we were just saying what the
last question could probably find a
nurse in fact I remember at that event
remember someone was raising their hand
or like talked to me after after this
event because I did exactly that right
so with Maura we don't know exactly what
she's going for she didn't say that but
let's just say she wants to be a marine
biologist uh-huh and like you know she
can't find a marine biologist who has
gone completely debt-free that
okay which what Mara needs is a recipe
she just needs some kind of hint
something to lead her along this path of
a debt-free college degree and guess
what
Anthony O'Neil has this amazing recipe
in this book debt-free degree so what
would your advice be to Mara here uh not
knowing what degree she's going into you
know man I think just a couple of weeks
ago you guys had one of my good friends
on Kenan Coleman and he wrote the book
called the proximity principle I would
recommend her get my book debt-free
degree but then also get his book the
proximity principle because he talks
about just being in the proximity of
others who have done something similar
to what you want to do so just because
you may not be able to find someone
who's done your specific degree like
what you said Ryan was getting around
people who are going to school debt-free
who have a heart you have a passion who
are living with intentionality who are
focused right now that's the medicine
that's the that's the people who you
need to be around so once you can get
ahold of that you can apply that now to
your life Amen man the proximity
principle that is a great recommendation
man I'd even think about that
um what I was in tell Marta to is like
this is the fun of life and this is
actually what makes you a better expert
at living life is when you can kind of
take someone's recipe and then you can
manipulate or maybe take a few
ingredients out of that recipe to make
it your own you don't have to find
someone who has exactly done your degree
who has been a marine biologist and went
through college for free but like you
said Nathan you just find people who
have at least got their degree for free
start there and then you can start
tweezing on the ingredients and make
your own but what's great about your
book Anthony is you have advice in here
about you know basically up from high
school until you graduate college on how
you can actually be get grants and help
yourself become debt-free and it's a
it's a step-by-step process it isn't
easy
like it definitely takes a lot of work
it's not gonna be easy and I said at the
front it's not gonna be easy at all but
I was easy is taking out a bunch of
loans that's easy right now it's gonna
be really difficult on you later that's
easy that's normal people are not buying
homes they're not getting married
they're not having a family because they
have all these student loans and
consumer debt and so for me inside of
this book what I'm teaching this
generation of friend
like hey work hard for four years work
hard for six years if you're gonna get
your master's degree
all right whether you work hard for four
to six years then it's been in next 20
30 40 years wishing that you would have
worked hard for those four six years
yeah you know I met a young lady 88
years old she's young to me and um she
was telling me that she has to work she
is cleaning up hotel rooms because she
doesn't have any retirement doesn't have
any savings and she was like son just
please use your youthfulness wisely she
took out student loans she has consumer
debt she has a lot of stuff over that
what we both teach against and I just
don't want to see that for no one
listening to this podcast watching us
online and I just really want to see
them do better yeah well now I'm gonna
congratulate you for moving forward past
some well you called toxic relationships
and Ryan and I often talk about having
to let those relationships go so that we
can move forward
start new empowering relationship
surround ourselves with with people who
are supportive and that's what she's
trying to find right now I don't know of
a specific platform where I'm like yes
you can go to nursing degree dot-com and
find other nurses who have graduated
debt-free or other marine biologists or
whatever but you you can you can find
people who are going to empower you
along along the way along along this
journey and as you you move forward and
you realize okay this is what I want to
do with my life I I'm surrounding myself
with people who who care and I care
about you so much that I don't want you
to be just burdened by an excessive
amount of debt going forward amen what
did you say about a with parents it's
like it's not your job to force your
kids what to do but but it's your job to
tell them no when they're gonna ruin
their financial life for the next few
years yes it's not your job to pretty
much you gotta work together to build
their future because what we're seeing
is we're seeing our students take a kids
approach to an adult decision and so we
need our young people to be guided by
their parents make sure that they're our
parents are helping to make better
decisions so in the future they can say
thank you yeah so what we're trying to
do for you here Mara is I don't go into
debt that's these are
got that in her head so we're here to be
your parents and say no like don't ruin
your financial life over the next few
years and yeah there are absolutely
people out there who whose recipes you
can you can take from the other thing I
love about what the Dave Ramsey team
always says maybe it was Dave who came
up with this but I know they all say it
is you know live like no one else now so
you can live and give like no one else
tomorrow yeah amen
yeah well I'm gonna send you a copy of
our book minimalism live a meaningful
life I think you'll find two chapters in
there particularly interesting and
useful there's a relationships chapter
in there so it talks about letting go of
those toxic relationships but then how
do you surround yourself with people who
are empowering and there's also a
passions chapter in there as well or
what you might say vocation or career or
creativity and those are two of the the
main values and Ryan's in my life I
think you'll find value and and that
book minimalism live a meaningful life
if you like our podcast you like the
audiobook version of that or you can get
the book book or the eBook version as
well podcast Sean will send that to you
alright Ryan what time is it you know
what time it is it's time for our
lightning round when we answer questions
from social media did we do we are at
the minimalists on Facebook Instagram
and Twitter and at Anthony o Neill you
remember this from oh when you were with
us in Birmingham I do yeah good question
so what we try to do here is answer the
question with a short shareable less
than 140 character response we put the
text in the show notes so you can copy
and share our pit the answers on social
media if you like and now Jessica puts
all of our quotes in one place minimal
maxims calm but really we can just
ramble on a bit until we find a good
answer all right our first question is
from Mesa what is a reasonable what is a
reasonable amount of money to invest in
a college education well here's my pit
the answer then I want to talk to
Anthony about this here we have the
saying quite often people say well you
get what you pay for and sometimes
that's true but my pithy answer is you
don't always get what you pay for
sometimes you're gonna pay a quarter
million dollars for a education but
you're gonna be broke and you may even
be broken by the whole process and feel
trapped now you've created your own
lavishly decorated prison cell and most
agrees that maybe maybe not most but
many degrees maybe
most are not worth the money you spend
on them in all degrees are certainly not
created equal so Anthony can we talk a
little bit about well we're some ways
that we can save money on on education
whether that is a community going to
Community College for a while maybe it's
a in-state tuition mmm you're hitting on
hitting on the head man I say this
everyone your dream schools in the
fordable school you're an affordable
school is a school you can graduate from
debt-free so we got to change the
definition of dream schools and so you
guys are right I mean right now going to
college getting a degree is expensive
but it doesn't have to be that expensive
so the average dream school not dream
school but if averaged in-state school
will cost you about six to eleven
thousand dollars so if we stay in-state
okay and if we live at home and let's
say we eat at home let's just say let's
do the math if we take ten thousand
dollars and divide that into twelve
that's eight hundred and thirty three
dollars a month you can drive for uber
and pay cash for college it's not gonna
eat on to borrow a dime and do nothing
let's say for an example you do stay on
the dorms and you do what that's amazing
gonna be about sixteen hundred dollars a
month so there are ways to do it but I
do not believe I gotta go back to you on
this one they agree with you like I'm
not borrowing a dime for college if you
step back and do the research main like
for an example in the state of North
Carolina
UNC Pembroke a school that probably a
lot of people haven't heard of because
they're not this big Ivy League school
but there are four year of fully
accredited nice solid school five
hundred dollars a semester for in-state
that's a thousand dollars a year that's
four thousand dollars for a four-year
degrees amazing for that's just their
tuition so if you stay at home you can
take care of that four thousand dollars
and what year and in the book you talk
about most employers are not they're not
gonna judge where you went to school I
mean there's there's a handful of
schools it's maybe six to 215 schools
whether it's Harvard or brown we had
Emily Oster from from Brown University
there's some Ivy League schools where
there's sure there's half a dozen to a
dozen of them basically well you know
it's funny even with that example I mean
she yes she is a analysis I mean she
is using her degree to write books but
like for all intents purposes like the
degree she could have got that degree
from anywhere and still do degree at
Brown she I think she went to Chicago
but she she's teaching at Brown and
there's a level of prestige from some of
these universities that will set you
above the rest of the pack but most of
these are really vanity it's it's it's
like having that vanity license plate or
or any other equivalent you are you
you're you have that just so you can say
well I graduated from Harvard but like
really right
really most employers in the real world
if they are looking for a degree if
they're looking for the degree not where
the degree came from now accreditation
is important so so looking at that
versus a I don't know an online
university something like that so the
there are differences even even there
but for most schools that are accredited
if you can if you can get out of there
with a degree and you can get out
debt-free you're gonna be in a much
better position than if you well but I
went to the Ohio State and now it's
people don't care as much hey hey guys
how do you know someone went to Harvard
don't worry they'll tell you it's like I
think it's it's it's almost passe like
our friend Adam who's a pastor in
Tennessee he always says well no went to
college in Ballston right no you went to
college yeah yeah yeah man you know it's
funny I
you're talking about Community College
when I was even reading that in your
book I wish I would have known about
going to college for free at Community
College I just had no clue but I will
say there's something I mean now being
you know I'll be 38 this is October the
month that were recording this oh I'll
be 38 this month and I can totally you
know accept going to a community college
not thinking anything of it however at
18 years old there's this stigma of like
oh I gotta go to Community College and I
guess the hatchback isn't cool so I
can't drive right exactly
but uh I guess I just want to point out
like I know that that's probably like if
there's like some high school kids or
even college because listen this was
like just there's no I'm going to
Community College you're 38 year old
self will thank you for going to
community college rather than racking up
a bunch of debt you know my pithy answer
here I really wanted to address this
this word reasonable because reasonable
for me is gonna be different for for
Josh it's gonna be different for Anthony
absolutely so to just say oh well here's
a reasonable amount of money that you
can afford I mean that's that's that's
perspectival so here's my pet the answer
most purchases are unreasonable if
you're in debt so most purchases like
yeah you gotta put food on the table if
you're in debt buy food yeah you got to
put gas in your car go buy gas but there
are a lot of purchases that are
unreasonable if you are in debt yeah and
so maybe we often think of we often
think of it as the opposite though right
like well the reasonable thing to do is
to go and get the the loans to go to the
best school and well you know I really
don't want to go to us I live in Ohio
and I really was hoping to go to Purdue
and it's out of state my parents will be
so proud of me yeah they're actually not
gonna be proud of your debt - stress
discontent rate or the life you now have
to live once you graduate in order to
pay off the debt and I would much rather
you yeah drive uber deliver pizzas
during college than having to do it for
a decade after you've already already
graduated or worse in my case I never
graduated college but I had student debt
so it was at the worst of both worlds
yes
yeah and so yeah I think that when we're
looking at when we're looking at being
reasonable maybe it's get a little bit
unreasonable relative to what the status
quo is because otherwise you know as
you're saying the debt is the normal
thing but to me really that should be
what is unreasonable man so Sean he
shrunk it sweet that to get reasonable
start to what you say live unreasonable
for the status quo she'll tweeze that
later all right before we get into our
added value segment and our listener
tips today it looks like we have a bunch
more surprise questions this week indeed
we do
let's see some of these questions here
do you support the proposal to cancel
all student loan debt why or why not
mm-hmm how we're gonna argue with
Anthony on this one I have a feeling how
can we get the government to stop
guaranteeing student loans does the lack
of financial literacy in our school
system create an ethical dilemma by
allowing teenagers access to high
interest rate loans what info should I
look for when refinancing a loan how do
you stay positive
if you've accrued overwhelming amounts
of debt and plus we have about a million
other questions for Anthony O'Neill also
we're gonna talk about one of our most
controversial statements Ryan there's no
such thing as good debts
my head exploded we're really gonna
unpack that we're gonna talk more about
that free degree as well and if you want
to hear all that you can listen to this
week's maximum episode available
exclusively on patreon that's right your
current listen to our weekly minimal
episode but each week Ryan and I record
an entirely different long-form maximal
episode available exclusively on the
minimalist private podcast which gives
us the private space we need to talk
about topics we don't usually discuss
and public Plus patreon is the best way
for us to fund this podcast and keep it
a hundred percent advertisement free
when you subscribe to the minimalist
private podcast on patreon you'll also
receive a personal link so that our
maximal episodes play in your favorite
podcast app you can find all the details
and all the good stuff including what we
recorded with Anthony this week such
good conversation very not beat it
actually changed quite a bit from the
minimal episode where I really felt like
we got into this groove and got really
excited talking about different jobs
students can take so if you know someone
who is a student who's getting ready to
go to college they're in college right
now or maybe someone who just has a lot
of student loan debt well then I think
this conversation is for you you can
find that all the details at the
minimalists comm slash support Ryan what
else you got for us this week yeah as
always read more get informed I just
wanted to read it reiterate what you
said Josh yeah Anthony O'Neill's a
genius
this debt-free degree book of his it is
a beautiful book for parents of kids who
were going to college or kids who were
already in college or if you're already
taking on a little bit of debt
a lot of that I think this book can
totally help you and then also I've got
some voicemail comments and tips from
our listeners check them out hi my name
is Yasiin Berra I'm from Winnipeg
Manitoba I'm calling to leave a
voicemail in response to the episode on
jobs there's a common thread in your
work that relates to living a meaningful
life and a lot of the discussion around
jobs tends to relate to finding
meaningful work and I think a shortcut
to finding meaningful work is actually
to just introduce the elements of
helping people so pretty much any kind
of work so if you were to take any sort
of job and just introduce an element of
helping people to the actual content of
the work that's a direct route to
finding more meaning in network in my
case I've done just that by by quitting
the the corporate job in order to start
a social enterprise and that's kind of
my my tip for this messages the concept
of a social enterprise is something that
people maybe want to familiarize
themselves with which is to say
basically conducting any sort of typical
business but perhaps structured as a
nonprofit where proceeds are used to
event some sort of social or
environmental cause and in that way
you're combining potentially the skills
that you've acquired in the context of a
regular job and coupling them with the
idea of helping people and I've found
that to be a really really great way to
find meaning in my work hi minimalists
this is Elizabeth from South Jordan Utah
and I was just listening to your podcast
about friends and relationships and
particularly your response to Rebecca's
question about how to improve
relationships or move on after a
relationship and as someone who does
believe that relationships are one of
the things that we take with us when we
go so to speak I really appreciate your
advice on how to take inventory of
relationships to make sure that we're
all staying on the on the right track
and on the path that we want to be I
would add to your advice to Rebekah
though just kind of a cautionary word
that the idea of not settling can
sometimes turn into nitpicking and I
would say that that's a very fine line
but an important one to remember
if not settling means that you have such
a long laundry list of trades that
you're never able to actually commit to
anyone you're gonna have a long and
miserable dating life I would also add
that it's important to remember that
sometimes the people who are the best
for us are the ones who challenge us the
most and in many ways are the most
different from us I know that's been my
experience with my relationship with my
husband and I wanted to put that out
there for anyone else who's listening
that just because it might be hard or
challenging doesn't mean that you're
settling in some ways you might be
winning in those situations more than
others
all right Joe thanks again to Anthony
for joining us today check out his book
that free degree you can also find him
at Anthony O'Neill comm we'll put a link
to that in the show notes and real quick
four right here right now here's one
thing that's going on in the life of the
minimalists have you checked out our
youtube channel recently we've got a
bunch of videos over there including two
full seasons of living room
conversations and Ryan I hear we might
we might get picked up for a third
season I was wondering what lrc meant I
think we should we should film every
time we move apartments and we call it
Josh and Ryan move Joshua ask Ryan to
move heavy objects yeah you know but we
have a couple of seasons of living room
conversations where we're either in my
living room or Ryan's living room and we
are answering your questions and who
knows we may even do a third season
coming up soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel
it's youtube.com slash the minimalist if
you have a comment question or
minimalism tip for our podcast leave us
a voicemail for zero six two one nine
seven eight three nine or you can send a
voice memo to podcast at the minimalists
comm if you want our show notes in your
inbox sign up for our email list over at
the minimalists comm it's right there at
the top you just enter your email
address we'll never send you spam or
junk but we will send you our podcast
show notes and also our simple Sunday
emails my favorite email list I belong
to yeah basically sending emails to
yourself yeah who rather would rather
get emails from that's great for added
value this week let's listen to a song
it's called cars at night from there's
this this new I think they're new I
couldn't find much about them online in
fact I I texted our friend Nate Peiffer
from Provo and I'm like do you have
anything to do with this album because
it sounds like you produced it but he
didn't he didn't know who they were it's
a two-person group called by the coast
and they have a new album I think it's
seven song so was that an album as in an
EP I don't know the kids are doing these
days it's called you but the song is
called cars at night and it's ethereal
it's beautiful I think you're gonna
enjoy it and if you live here today with
just one message we hope it's this love
people and use things because the
opposite never works thanks for
listening yeah we'll see you next time
minimus